this week on brian ross investigates
new developments in the search for
justice for robert loggins
the mississippi man who ended up dead in
police custody in a county jail
after officers appear to use a
knee-to-neck restraint
for some three minutes this man has got
no heartbeat
and he's not breathing authorities
called it an accident
but forensic pathologist dr michael
ponton says otherwise
the manner of death is properly homicide
with the department of justice now
launching investigations
into the police in minneapolis in
louisville and elsewhere
we'll talk with one of the mississippi
lawmakers who says the fed should come
to his state
too plus catastrophe in india
four hundred thousand covet 19 cases
every day
hospitals swarmed bodies piling up
law and crime producer samantha kelly on
the scene in mumbai
with the very latest beds are
limited or non-existent oxygen is low
plasma is low and this week's winners
and losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of meteorite
tucker you scrunch-faced fear baboon
from the lawn crime trial network this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague at law and crime ronda
schwartz
and ronda we begin with the push for
justice for a young man
who died in police custody in
mississippi a push led by state
legislators
and we'll talk to one of them in just a
moment from the state capitol of jackson
rhonda
as we've reported brian a new video
obtained by the mississippi center for
investigative reporting on whose board i
served
shows police seeming to use the same
need and neck restraint that led to the
death of george floyd
in this case the man's name is robert
loggins 23 zola
outside in the sky
robert loggins was already in bad shape
but very much alive
when officers brought him to the county
jail in grenada mississippi
the 26 year old loggins had been taken
into custody a short while
earlier around 5 30 in the morning 9-1-1
where's your emergency
calling for help responding to a call
about a stranger in a backyard
police body cam videos show officers
used a taser on him
at least eight times as he resisted
arrest take your hands my bunny
take your hands my friend take your hand
my friend
one officer hits him in the head with a
flashlight
but his treatment got worse at the
county jail
the jail surveillance video shows
loggins being carried in
handcuffed his pants left at his ankles
a few minutes later five officers pile
on top of loggins
after he apparently resisted efforts to
put a second set of handcuffs on him
one officer appears to put his knee to
logan's neck
this lasts about three and a half
minutes when the officers finally get
off him
his body appears limp the supervisory
sergeant
calls dispatch he's bleeding from his
mouth he's got
uh he's bleeding from his leg and until
i have a mission and i'm not going to
touch him some
six minutes later the supervisory
sergeant finally checked loggins for his
pulse
there was none sheriff's farmer i need
an analyst at the grenade county jail
now i got an unresponsive
uh offender he was just brought in here
by the y'all
uh mr merriman and two other officers
this man has got
no heartbeat and he's not breathing i
want them officers back over here and i
want ambulance here
this is sergeant clark get him here now
it took another three minutes
for the emt crew to arrive efforts to
revive robert loggins
were too late the state pathologist
ruled his death
an accident saying it was due to
methamphetamine
toxicity we're joined now by jerry
mitchell of the mississippi center for
investigative reporting which first
broke the story
jerry thanks so much for joining us what
are we seeing on that
tape with mr loggins as he's brought
into the jail and they're getting on top
of him
what's happening what triggered that
moment he seemed kind of out of it
he uh had supposedly been doing some
meth and he also had some mental issues
so when they were talking to him he was
spouting off scripture and talking in
tongues and
you know things like that i mean you
know things that that indicated he
wasn't necessarily all there
and um and so they brought him in
and and apparently the wrestling officer
wanted his handcuffs back so literally
these officers just pile on top of him
in order to
switch these handcuffs and they're
literally on top of him for about three
and a half minutes
and then when they get off of him just
no movement at all brian
i mean just nothing the guy doesn't move
at all and
and as you've reported before about this
positional affixia
uh you know if you just
just the act alone of of handcuffing
someone behind the back
and leave them on their stomach can that
alone can cause
issues in terms of people being able to
breathe and then when you
add weight to the back it increases that
risk even more of people
not being able to to breathe
so this is very much exactly what
happened to george floyd
absolutely absolutely it's the same kind
of thing and you see the one officer
who actually looks like he's kneeling on
the neck
as well so you see almost identical to
kind of some of the things we saw in
george floyd case
mitchell asked renowned forensic
pathologist dr michael baden to review
the case
i shared the autopsy with dr michael
baden and he said look this is a
homicide this isn't an accident you can
tell
by the video that you know this wasn't
an accident
in my opinion the the true manner of
death is restraint asphyxia
inability to breathe due to the pressure
that was being put on his back during
restraint
and the manner of death is properly
homicide
homicide meaning that death at the hands
of another
the the amount of drug taken that by him
was enough to cause bizarre behavior
and inability to understand what the
police were asking him to do
and respond appropriately but not enough
to cause death a very low
level for causing death
we're now joined from jackson
mississippi by mississippi state senator
john horn
and senator as you look at that video
and think about it this happened more
than three years ago or almost three
years ago and yet only now is it coming
to light
what needs to be done
well we think that the situation is so
similar to the george ford case
that especially given the fact that
attorney general
garner is calling for uh an evaluation
of certain police forces that it ought
to be expanded to this particular case
in mississippi and that we all also need
to be looking at and reviewing policies
of police officers and and other law
enforcement
manuals and and whatnot as it relates to
how they handle
detainees
as you know this video only became
available because somebody gave it to
jerry mitchell uh it was kind of kept
quiet
for two and a half years now that it's
out
what's the reaction in mississippi to
this
uh there's a lot of shock but there's
also
uh okay here's business as usual uh
given the state's history
uh and the fact that uh this is not just
a problem
in minneapolis or in louisville it's
been a problem historically in
mississippi
for decades and we want to get to the
bottom of it and make sure that this
doesn't happen again
the state authorities say this was an
accident due to
methamphetamine toxicity are you buying
that
no the video says otherwise
uh and according to dr baden the amount
of toxicity from methamphetamines
in his system uh do not uh corroborate
the conclusion that that was the cause
of death uh
his his cause of death was at the hands
of another and it looks like the other
was the police department
so in this case state authorities tried
to call it an accident now they're being
called on that what about the state
authorities who said it was an accident
uh
are they involved in a kind of cover-up
do you think
i don't think so at the time that the
determination was made they went by the
word of the police and they
they went by a lot of photographs that
they saw but the video
had not surfaced it's only because this
video
it's only because this video has
surfaced that we're now able to
call for an investigation so
senator you want the federal government
to investigate the fbi to come in and
take a look at the
practices of what's happening well
when i saw the story and contacted jared
mitchell who's a good friend of mine and
whose instincts i really trust
i felt that the legislative black caucus
should take action
so i contacted our chairman uh who is
senator
angela turner forward and uh
after she saw what i had seen she then
wrote
formal letters to our department of
public safety commissioner
and also to attorney general garner
calling for
an opening of an investigation all right
state senator john horn thank you so
much for being with us here tonight
thank you brian all right coming up next
the catastrophe in india coveted 19
out of control bodies piling up in the
street
we'll see long crime producer samantha
kelly
with the latest on the ground in mumbai
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
as we all know by now no one is really
safe from covert 19
until the pandemic is brought under
control worldwide
which is why what is happening now in
india is so
significant rhonda 400
000 new cases a day bodies on the street
hospitals overwhelmed
no oxygen supplies it is
just at the worst in the world at the
moment
we're joined now from mumbai india by
samantha kelly we know her
sam long crime producer working on
number of projects with us and sam
how is it there hi brian thanks for
having me
um you know it's tough here right now
the cases in mumbai maharashtra and
india in general are really really still
skyrocketing um
and it feels you know i was in new york
in march and april of 2020 and i would
say it
feels very similar in tenor and also at
the emergency level and when you walk
around is everyone wearing a mask
are people even outside at all you know
people are wearing masks
which is great um that is something that
everyone has been doing for
months now but people are out especially
since the first
wave you know hit and retreated
people you know need to go about their
business and the economy is suffering so
people are out and
doing things and you know getting
essential services
done the reports we see give a sense of
doom that really the
medical system is overwhelmed that the
bodies are piling up on the streets
is that an accurate picture you know it
unfortunately
is you know i myself haven't seen
you know the bodies portion but it is a
dire situation
beds are limited or non-existent oxygen
is low
plasma is low people are trying to get
you know oxygen tanks sent to their
individual family members from different
countries
it's tough it's not a good situation
there's been a talk in many countries
sending aid including
the united states to india is there a
sense in india that
other countries have not come to the aid
of india quickly enough
you know i think that there are some
people here that might feel that way
you know india was really they did great
for so
long and so they you know exported their
vaccines
in a large number to other countries and
you know now they're facing a shortage
and you know countries are slow to
respond and i think there's a little bit
of a
you know we helped you where are you now
and so is there
anger among people in india about its
government
and foreign allies
you know i think that there's been some
reports of
folks here feeling like this situation
has become politicized
especially with the current government
and there's elections happening right
now and so
there were some rallies that continued
to happen past the point where that
level of gathering should have been
happening
there were a few large religious
ceremonies that continued to happen
um and so people were very angry about
that and
frustrated with the government for not
stepping in sooner
um i would say anger towards other
countries
i've heard a little less of that and i
would say that people are coming
together
and so for people in india are vaccines
available are they in very short supply
so they they were available and actually
as of may 1st
in maharashtra where i am located right
now
they were supposed to be available for
18 and above
um for people starting may 1st but
there is a very short supply right now
all right well sam uh stay safe uh look
forward to seeing you again once this
pandemic passes and
thank you so much for being with us here
tonight
thanks so much brian really appreciate
it
now let's go to dr william shaffner at
the university vanderbilt university's
medical school one of the country's
leading experts on infectious diseases
and dr shaffner as we watched this
report from india
why is it so significant to pay
attention to what's happening there
yeah brian those reports are really very
very serious i've heard
similar grim reports we're interested in
what's happening in
india not just for humanitarian reasons
but reasons of our own self-interest you
know
every time the virus has hits
someone new and multiplies infects them
the virus mutates and most of those
mutations are harmless
but every once in a while you get a
mutation or a series of mutations
that can send off a variant and these
variant
viruses can be either more transmissible
more contagious they could potentially
be more serious
if you become infected and most
important
some of these variants might indeed be
able to evade the protection
that we get from our vaccines which
would mean then
if that variant came to the united
states
and started to spread we would have to
have a new vaccine
and start all over again so whatever
happens there
is important to us here and they thought
they were way ahead of the curve and
then they got hit very hard
what's the lesson for the united states
oh the lesson is
we've learned this lesson ourselves open
up too soon
allow these mass gatherings without
masks close together
even if they're out of doors and there's
the potential
for widespread in the meantime let's
keep
vaccinating and we have lots of hesitant
and even
very reluctant people at the moment whom
we have to bring into the fold
and get vaccinated very quickly we now
see
new york city reopening completely full
capacity
is it too soon well most of us are a
little worried about that
right we would prefer to go a little bit
more slowly
but if we keep vaccinating i think our
vaccination program
can finally get ahead of this virus but
we have to keep vaccinating
and people who are resisting the
vaccines
they're not helping at all are they well
we need to reach out to them understand
what their issues are
and there are many different issues with
different people and try to respond
and make them comfortable and reassured
that getting vaccine
is the best for them their families and
their communities
and what do you say to people who say i
just don't want it i'm afraid of it
well i talk to them some more to find
out what their issues are
and if they refuse i say you can always
come back
we're ready to vaccinate anytime you're
ready
all right dr william shaffner at
vanderbilt university thank you so much
once again for being with us
tonight and for your insights my
pleasure brian
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
about what's going on in the media
you're watching
brian ross investigates on the law and
crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite and
we're joined by aida mclaughlin who's
the editor-in-chief of videoite
which like the law and crime trial
network is part of the dan abrams media
empire
and aidan we begin with your winner it's
john oliver let's take a look
the cdc is being cautious and wants to
be sure that it is not
spreading bullshit around during a
global pandemic
like a frozen dinner duke with a tv show
anyway
i hope that answers at least one of your
gaped mouthed bad faith wonderings
tucker you scrunch-faced fear baboon
stop listening to what joe rogan tells
you he's a
moron and those are his words not mine
he is funny and right on point aidan
he is so john alert he did a lengthy uh
segment uh it starts actually the whole
the entire length of his hbo show
about the media figures that are pushing
a vaccine conspiracy theory
um he took an aim mostly at tucker
carlson the fox news
primetime host but also joe rogan who
got into some hot water uh last week
when he basically said that he didn't
think that young healthy people should
be getting the vaccine
joe rogan is obviously a massively
popular podcaster he's a legion of
fans a really big following and they
hang on to his every word um
he got yelled at by a lot of people
online and eventually issued a statement
saying
um that he is not a doctor and that
people should not be getting their
vaccine advice from him
um tucker carlson has never apologized
for his commentary on vaccines
um i think the the one part that john
oliver nailed there
um was tucker crosston does this odd
thing where he said
uh a couple weeks ago maybe the vaccine
doesn't work and that's why
restrictions aren't being lifted fast
enough as
john oliver correctly pointed out tucker
also knows that the vaccines work
you can google that it's very easily
accessible information have a news
host on a news network raise these
questions about things that we know and
that are easily
uh you know obtainable information is
incredibly dangerous especially when it
comes to something like vaccines
right and this week's uh losers uh trio
of the new york times the washington
post and
nbc news what's going on there
that's right it's a real black eye for
these news outlets basically the
washington post was
first to report that giuliani had been
giving a defensive briefing
by the federal federal government that
he was the target of a russian
disinformation campaign um that was
followed up by a report in the new york
times which said it had confirmed
washington post reporting
then nbc news said it had confirmed the
reporting um
it turned out uh much in sort of in
agreement with
giuliani's denials that he had ever
briefed on this um
that that was not true that that
defensive briefing never happened um so
each of these outlets had to deliver
a correction to their stories um nbc
news in particular just delivered quite
a lengthy correction
um and it's sort of embarrassing for the
network uh networks and
the papers but it's a good thing that
they issued a correction on it
um i suspect they all had the same
source here
um each source was anonymous and uh
and you know that's always been a
problem for news outlets um and it's but
at least it's good that they correct it
well you're only as good as your sources
as everyone knows and in this case that
was a huge problem
aidan mclaughlin thank you so much for
being with us by the way they called it
a correction not a retraction right
they did indeed yeah it was a correction
on the story that particular piece of
information
okay all right and thanks all of you for
joining us thanks to our great staff at
long crime for getting us on the air
and off here
[Music]
[Applause]
you